عوده تدريجيه لحركه طيران في الولايات
المتحده مكتبه بريطانيه تثير جدلا بطريقه
عرضها لكتاب الامير هاري بسبب زيدان ايقاف
مؤقت لرئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد خلل الفنيه
حركه الطيران بشكل تدريجي في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده
التقنيه
الذي يزود طيارين بالاشعارات التي يحتاجون
لقراءتها قبل الطيران فيما قالت المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض كريم جون بيار انه لا
يوجد دليل على هجوم الكتروني في هذه
المرحله لكن الرئيس وجهها وزاره النقل
باجراء تحقيق كامل في الاسباب التي ادت
الى فوضى غير مسبوقه في الحركه الجويه
الامريكيه
بعد طرح مذكرات الامير هاري رسميا
بالاسواق حول العالم اثارت مكتبه بريطانيه
جدلا واسعا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بطريقه عرضها للكتاب على واجهه المكتبه
الزجاجيه مكتبه بورت في بلده سويندون عرضت
كتاب الامير هاري سبير او الاحتياطي او
البديل بجانب روايه للمؤلفه بيلا ماكي
التي تحمل عنوان كيف تقتل عائلتك في اشاره
الى ما يرمي اليه الامير هاري ضد عائلته
فيما حفظت تغريده المكتبه التي احتلت على
الصوره تعرض الكتاب حظيت بعشرات الاف
الاعجابات واعاده التغريد والتعليقات التي
ابدت الاعجاب بنهج المكتبه
بعد تصريحاته الاخيره ضد زين الدين زيدان
قرر الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم ايقاف
رئيسه عن ممارسه مهامه وتكليف نائبه فيليب
ديالو بتسيير الشؤون الاتحاد مؤقتا موقع
فرانس 24
زين الدين زيدان اذن بسبب تصريحاته ضد
زيدان التي اثار لاعبين وسياسيين اذ اجابه
ردا على سؤال عما اذا كان زيدان سيدرب
الان المنتخب البرازيلي بدلا من الفرنسيه
انا لا ابالي يمكنه الذهاب الى اي مكان
يريد
في جريمه مروعه هزت ليبيا اقدمت سيده على
قتل زوجها في مدينه طرابلس بضربه على راسه
بعصا مكنسه حديديه اما السبب تكسيره
فناجين قهوه في المطبخ وزاره الداخليه
اوضحت ان الزوجه الجاليه حاولت تظليل
العداله بزعها ان اشخاص مجهولين اقتحموا
منزلها وعذبها وقتلوا زوجها غير انه
بالتحقيق معها اعترفت بارتكابها واقعه
القتل قائله ان زوجها لا يسمع كلامها ولا
يطبق تعليماتها واوضحت انها لم تكن تنوي
قتله لكنها ضربته على راسه ليفقد الوعي
ويسقط ارضا ويفارق الحياه
وفي خبرنا الاخير يوصل الجنيه المصري
تراجعه السريع بعد ما وصل سعر صرف الدولار
الى 32 جنيها للمره الاولى على الاطلاق مع
توقعات باستمرار هبوط العمله المصريه
لمستويات قياسيه الهبوط التاريخي للجنيه
ياتي في الوقت الذي تواجه فيه السوق
السوداء خسائر عنيفه مع هدوء الطلب من قبل
المستوردين وشركات الاستيراد بعد تحرك
الحكومه والبنك المركزي بشكل مكثف لتوفير
الدولار للمستوردين عبر السوق الرسميه كان
الجنائيها فقد خلال اشهر اكثر من نصف
قيمتها امام العملات الاجنبيه تزامنا مع
موجه تضخم مزعه تضرب بلا
[موسيقى]